there is plenty of opportunity when we
speak a foreign language to come across
as silly hi there steve kaufman here and
today i want to talk about cultural
sensitivities
and
specific cultural aspects of a language
and why we should ignore them
when we start into a new language
and when it's appropriate to
be more focused on these things
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
if you're following me on a podcast
service please leave a review
so the reason i bring this up is that i
was on twitter
and i had done a video earlier where i
said that when i start a new language
i'm really not interested in the sort of
detailed you know names of relatives
because many languages have more
specific terms for relatives you know an
uncle is not just an uncle it's either
the mother's brother or the father's
brother or cousin could be any number of
combinations of relatives and so an
older sister younger sister older
brother younger brother all of these
things
are in some languages there's a lot of
detail there that we don't have in
english
and these are things that we eventually
need to know if we're going to be
operating comfortably in the language
but it's not a good idea in my
experience to be confronted with these
things
at an early stage in the language
the same goes with sort of
polite language or different level
levels of politeness
or
introducing you know special festivals i
remember
in japanese there was early on there was
a lesson on irises and blue flags
there's some festival in
japan that i still don't know anything
about
there's a tendency on the part of people
who write textbooks
to want to focus on what is different
and call it esoteric and potentially
attractive in the new culture
but in my view
these things if they come early
in the language learning process they
just add more difficulty
uh we're learning a new language new
words new sounds
my experience is the more we can deal
with things that are familiar to us
familiar situations a husband and wife a
brother and a sister without worrying
about turns for older or younger just
people interacting with each other using
common
vocabulary if we can have this more
familiar
content then it's going to be easier to
learn the language
and
if we don't learn the term for older
sister younger sister
at the beginner stage
we'll eventually learn it and the same
is true with different levels of
politeness now
so i said something to this effect in a
video and you know i have been
having sort of extracts or excerpts of
some of my previous videos
featured again
so this came up and then this generated
this flurry of activity on twitter
now
you know and and i can't remember what
the wording was but somebody sort of
commented you know
uh i'm shocked that
you would
ignore these fine aspects of
the culture
many of the beginner words are
tied up with these aspects of the
culture and i said well give me some
examples and the person didn't come back
with any examples
other than to say that she was shocked
that i was prepared to be rude
in the language
um you know i think there is a tendency
when we learn
a language where the culture is very
different or even not so different
that we become oversensitive to these
cultural differences
it's not easy to offend people
it's not easy to be rude
uh just because we use the wrong word or
the wrong
degree of politeness or or anything else
if we are a beginner first of all when
we're starting in the language we are
in my opinion better off to focus on
input so you're just absorbing the
language
and you may notice that sometimes it's
vu and sometimes it's too
for example in french polite or
you know
familiar not familiar
and grazie we get used to this and maybe
we find an explanation somewhere
and we kind of tuck that in the back of
our minds
and then when we go to speak eventually
a few months later we start speaking we
may get it wrong but we won't offend
anyone
any more than if someone who is a
beginner in english speaks to us and
uses the wrong word or
says something wrong i mean unless
they're swearing at us we're not going
to be offended
we won't necessarily consider the person
rude we might we might find
them silly i mean there is plenty of
opportunity when we speak a foreign
language to come across as silly that
comes with a territory
you have to be willing to
sound less intelligent
somewhat sillier
than in your own language
that is something we have to accept if
we're speaking a foreign language
but at the early stages i think
everything should be done
to make it as easy as possible to
get the language in you so familiar
situations but here are these different
words and here is how they say good
morning or here is how they say i'm
going to work today or whatever it is
very standard type
uh
words and situations that's why our many
stories at link are largely called
culturally neutral they're not
completely culturally neutral that's not
possible they were written by someone
who actually a canadian woman who
teaches english in japan so she's going
to reflect that to some extent but in
many cultures of the world we get up we
make breakfast people go to work
uh people might be cleaning their
apartment or their house or any of the
different situations that we have there
are relatively relatively cultural
neutral they don't go into
very culturally specific things
and our many stories now those are our
existing 60 mini stories i think would
be great to have some culturally
specific mini stories so that the
principle of the many stories the
repetition
the high frequency verbs
we contain we sort of maintain that but
we introduce things that are specific to
persian culture which would be fun for
me because i'm learning pertinent or
arabic culture or egypt
or or france or china or russia or japan
so we can have those
uh
i think those are better
later now
bear in mind i'm talking about
my personal perspective on this of
course i eventually want to get into the
cultural or culturally specific things
and i want to choose those things that i
find interesting and
it may be that
you know japanese cooking is what i'm
interested in more so than say japanese
dance for example or i'm not interested
in anime or we we can choose those
things that we're interested in and that
will inspire us further in our study but
if at an early stage we don't get the
degree of politeness correct in korean
or japanese that doesn't mean we won't
be able to get it right later on this is
another thing because there's a number
of exchanges here on twitter and people
implying well you know if you don't get
it right at the beginning you'll forever
be speaking impolitely that's not true
there are any number of things that we
get
wrong at the early stages from the tense
to the
person to the gender to and that doesn't
mean that at some stage
because we've been listening and reading
so much and becoming more and more
familiar with the language at some stage
we'll get better and we'll get better
with all of these aspects
so i think the this idea that you have
to get and it's a bit like
you know a lot of things that are
typically introduced early on in in
these beginner books including colors
for example i have no capacity for
absorbing seven colors uh in one lesson
uh or all the numbers in one lesson
uh it's just part and parcel of all the
things that will gradually be be
absorbed by the brain in due course
and ideally absorbed
within content that we can cope with
that is relatively familiar
and you know words that repeat often and
gradually we get better and as we build
up we pursue areas of interest or we get
better and we realize actually if you
talk about levels of politeness in
japanese and chinese
we realize as we understand and hear
better what other people are saying and
we understand better in what situations
which words are used which levels of
politeness are used we then get better
at doing that ourselves
and that's part of the reason why i'm
very much against uh teaching slang
because
you also have to have a good sense of
where
slang is appropriate
not to mention swear words which are
can be used at some point but are best
avoided until we have a good sense of
when to use them similarly
the levels of politeness we will
eventually develop a feel for when to
use them
and the idea that somehow people in
other cultures are easily offended
if we get things wrong
even though we know that we ourselves
wouldn't be offended by someone getting
similar things wrong why would they be i
think there's sort of an oversensitivity
to what we perceive to be more
you know exotic cultures that we have to
step very carefully walk on eggshells
i don't believe that i think people are
similar everywhere
they encourage you to learn the language
not everyone not everyone there will be
people who might be offended there are
people who have no patience sort of to
deal with you if you're learning their
language and you butcher it there's
always those people but the majority of
people aren't that way so i just thought
i would
comment on that so when you get started
in a language i say go easy on the
culture you'll get to it eventually and
you'll find those things that interest
you and and presumably it's a it's a a
general interest in the culture that has
you know encouraged you sort of to learn
the language but it'll all come in due
course you don't have to get it in the
beginner textbooks so
i just thought would be something that
i've been you know engaging with people
on twitter and of course twitter is a
very special kind of medium people who
tend to just say things without really
having thought them through
uh
but it's it's fun it's you get a sense
of what some people are thinking how
representative they are
it's hard to gauge because if you're in
a particular silo you'll get a lot of
people commenting reflecting a similar
point of view that may not be very
representative
so um yeah with that the idea of culture
i've always been interested in culture
but not up front and i'll leave you with
a couple of videos that talk about
getting started in a language and the
role of culture
thank you for listening bye for now